so it's freshman year i wanted to do
like an activity what i tried to do was
parkour and it was like supposed to be a
quote-unquote beginner parkour thing i
showed up at the place and we met in the
parking garage and it was me and three
other dudes and one of them had done
parkour
maybe and the other three of us were
just like complete newbies getting in
there and just trying to have an
adventure we were jumping around the
fourth level of the parking garage and
so we were leaping around there we were
jumping around we would go
like over the edge
with like 50 feet below us and we would
just like dance around there for a
little bit and so we actually end up
like dropping down two floors anyway but
the stairs or the ramp inside so like
crawling around the building outside and
i don't die at this point
but we get down to the second level and
it's time to drop from the second story
and do a sweet tuck and roll into this
little grass patch so the first guy goes
and he goes like drop and tuck and roll
and it's perfect and he's fine and then
the second guy goes and he manages to do
it a tuck and roll and it's at this
point that i realized they assumed i
knew how to do a tuck and roll
which i had never done in my life
so there i am hanging off by one hand
from the second story ledge of a
concrete parking garage looking at a
tiny patch of grass that i'm supposed to
hit and in my head i'm like it can't be
that hard
and so they're all giving me encouraging
words really you can do it and i'm like
i got this i got this
and so i drop
and i landed from the second story
straight onto my ass
like 100
full-on
into my ass i felt something pop weirdly
no pain
but like this stunned thing where you're
like on the ground like uh am i dead
am i dead and like weirdly enough i i
seemed totally fine i wasn't by the way
i want to mention i was not okay uh and
then the guy behind me is about to go
and uh he
drops
and instead of falling on his ass he
fell on his face
like his legs hit he went forward he did
not roll right into his face and chest
hit the ground and you just hear him go
like oh
god like just all the wind dropped out
of him and he's desperately like on the
ground trying to get a sucking breath so
you know after a while we're just
standing there we're looking at this guy
dying on the ground really what do we do
but he gets up like he's he gets up and
he plays it off like i'm fine but
clearly his ribs are broken like
straight up his ribs are broken and so
he gets up he's looking good
i think i think i need i think i'm good
for today guys
i'm gonna lay down so it's like he
stumbles off and we're watching him we
watch him walk away for like five
minutes so we're watching him stumble
away about the time he disappears out of
you behind you know those hills like we
look at each other really all right
let's keep going guys just like
let's see we go over to this building we
get to the roof we hear sirens when
we're up on the roof for some reason in
our brain we're like they're coming for
us
they found out
we went into the forbidden zone and like
you know
they're gonna get us on this roof we've
committed horrible crimes so we all
panic right so we panic and we run off
and then again they drop down from this
second story ledge on to this grassy
part so i find myself
once again hanging by one hand from a
second story ledge looking down but in
my mind in my mind at this moment i'm
like okay i went backwards that last
time i'll go forwards this time i know
what my mistake was
and so i drop and i'm like forward
forward forward i saw them roll on like
their shoulder and so my legs hit the
ground i go forward
and i put a hundred percent of my weight
right onto my shoulder and i don't move
and it's just like i hit the ground my
shoulder just
well thank god you did it that right way
that time yeah thank god he rolled
forward and saved it i like am down
there for a while
for a while and i'm like i'm okay
okay i'm okay and i look up and they're
gone
[Laughter]
they taught you
[Laughter]
i think the only way that could be
better at all is if you look up and
there's like two cops just standing
there just like we know where you were
that's the forbidden roof i hope they
lost their parkour teaching license
after this
[Music]